en route vers le noyau on croise des
mitochondries les centrales énergétiques
de la cellule
c'est dans ses mitochondries que se
trouve notre première micro marché cette
structure fonctionne comme un moteur à
rotation et tourne autour d'un axe cette
machine produit de la tp
une source d'énergie indispensable
fonctionnement de la cellule à
l'intérieur de cette machine sera pas
comme des roues qui lie keaton c'est à
ce moment là que la tp est formé par le
fait que les protons d'un côté de la
membrane sont transportés à l'intérieur
de ces verrous keaton et la roue qui
tourne maintenant fabriquer des
molécules dans tp cette roue qui tourne
on le visualiser par des microscopes
donc ça existe pour de vrai dans tout ça
ça existe pour les vrais ailiers ici qui
est juste une représentation artistique
de ce qu'on imagine un livre dans la
cellule 90 où ça s'est basé sur les
observations bien spécifique avec
plusieurs prix nobel qui ont été données
pour chacune de ces emplacements